io sono una ricercatrice nel campo della
scienza dei materiali
si tratta di un settore della ricerca
scientifica che vede coinvolte diverse
figure professionali tra cui i chimici
fisici ingegneri in generale spetta
chimici ruolo di creare nuovi materiali
a partire dalla loro formulazione io
sono un ingegnere e mi occupo di
cambiarne forme composizione al fine di
conferirgli particolari proprietà i
materiali con cui lavoro sono noti sotto
il nome di polimeri ovvero macromolecole
cioè costituite da un gran numero di
unità ripetenti uguali o diversi
legati tra di loro per formare una
catena possono essere di origine
sintetica semi sintetica anche naturale
ci sono diverse tecnologie
che possono tornare utili per cambiare
la forma dei polimeri e la scienza va
nella direzione in cui ognuno possa dar
sfogo alla propria immaginazione in un
modo molto semplice ed anche piuttosto
intuitivo
sto pensando per esempio le stampanti 3d
per cui un operatore può essere un
privato cittadino o anche per esempio un
equipe di medici chirurghi
eppure nell'immaginario collettivo al
termine polimeri o plastica siamo soliti
associare la bottiglia dell'acqua
minerale
eppure essa è costituita da uno delle
tantissime specie di polimeri che
vengono oggi utilizzati se ve ne sono
alcuni che possono assumere delle forme
talmente confortevoli da poter essere
indossati queste sono delle maglie di
uso comune è sempre più di frequente
leggiamo sulle etichette
c'è la presenza di materiali come il
poliestere nylon l'acrilico in effetti
polimeri sono entrati nell'industria
tessile alla fine degli anni 800 primi
anni del novecento perché avevano delle
caratteristiche peculiari che li
rendevano superiori rispetto alle fibre
naturali
parlo per esempio della flessibilità
dove si tratta di flessibilità non solo
di forma ma anche degli utilizzi che se
ne può fare oppure una maggiore
durabilità nel tempo maggiore elasticità
avrete sicuramente sentito parlare e
avrete sicuramente utilizzato dei
tessuti in microfibra
la microfibra è un filato due volte più
leggero della seta è tre volte più
leggero del cotone viene realizzato
attraverso un processo di filatura che
permette di modificarne forma e
dimensioni cambiando le dimensioni
dell'orifizio da cui fuoriesce
caratteristiche principali di un tessuto
in microfibra sono l'estrema leggerezza
e sofficità al tatto ma la cosa molto
interessante è che le rende così
estremamente versatili e che con lo
stesso materiale è possibile realizzare
dei tessuti traspiranti o anche di
tessuti anti vento
ebbene le dimensioni di una microfibra
sono di circa 10 micrometri
ovvero confrontabili con le dimensioni
del capello di un uomo
è possibile realizzare delle fibre
centinaia di volte più piccole
questa immagine ad alta risoluzione
realizzato presso i nostri laboratori
mostra il cappello di un uomo al centro
avvolto da un intricata matassa di fili
si tratta di nano fibre di polimero
centinaia di volte più sottili rispetto
al capello e quindi centinaia di volte
più sottili rispetto alle microfibre i
nostri studi hanno dimostrato che
cambiando forma dimensioni di questa
matassa di fibre e possibile conferire
al tessuto delle particolari proprietà e
questi tessuti sono interessanti in
svariati settori applicativi per esempio
nella filtrazione
la superficie specifica di questi
tessuti aumento così tanto che è
possibile per esempio filtrare gli
oggetti più piccoli il particolato più
piccolo
o ancora è possibile utilizzare dei
polimeri
biocompatibili
significa che possono interagire con i
sistemi viventi il senza alterarne le
funzioni vitali per realizzare degli
schifosi è un termine inglese che
significa impalcatura lische fall sono
molto utilizzati in ingegneria tissutale
rigenerativa e sono dei supporti che
vengono offerti al tessuto da rigenerare
ancora è possibile utilizzare dei
polimeri
biocompatibili e anche piezoelettrici
per trasformare energia meccanica in
energia elettrica
ed è questo quello di cui parleremo oggi
vediamo innanzitutto
come funziona un materiale
piezoelettrico nello schema che state
vedendo è rappresentato dal rettangolo
centrale che è connesso tramite due capi
elettrici due cavi elettrici
all'estremità di uno strumento chiamato
voltmetro che uno strumento in grado di
misurare una differenza di potenziale
immaginiamo di applicare una pressione a
questo materiale esso di conseguenza si
deformerà ogni volta che il materiale si
deforma si ingenerano sulla sua
superficie delle cariche elettriche di
segno opposto che danno origine ad una
differenza di potenziale che andremo a
leggere sul nostro strumento il volto m
vediamo una piccola simulazione
all'aumentare della pressione che
applichiamo aumenterà di conseguenza la
deformazione indotta nel materiale ed
aumenterà il valore di voltaggio che
andrei a leggere
nella vita comune il principio della
pizza elettricità è molto utilizzato
pensiamo per esempio all'accendino ogni
volta che noi premiamo il materiale
piezoelettrico che si trova al suo
interno si deforma e deformando si dà
origine ad un arco elettrico all'interno
del box che contiene il gas e quindi si
genera la fiamma ci sono molti materiali
piezoelettrici che sono di origine
naturale
il quarzo per esempio è la
piezoelettricità e il principio di
funzionamento alla base degli orologi al
quarzo
altri materiali naturali sono il topazio
anche lo zucchero di canna e si possono
fare tanti altri esempi di oggetti che
contengono materiali piezoelettrici e
che ne sfruttano il funzionamento per
esempio sensori dell'airbag o anche la
chitarra acustica
ma cosa hanno in comune questi materiali
che ho adesso menzionato l'accendino la
chitarra
l'airbag
si tratta di oggetti dotati di una
propria forma anche rigidi e molti casi
fragili
fragili così come sono fragili dei
materiali piezoelettrici che ne
abilitano la funzione infatti nella
maggior parte dei casi materiali
piezoelettrici utilizzati sono di
origine ceramica e hanno un altro grave
difetto e cioè che avendo forma propria
de cento passi fragili non sono conforma
bili cioè non sono in grado di assumere
la forma dell'oggetto sul quale vengono
posizionati
questo è un materiale piezoelettrico in
forma di tessuto
esce così come appare estremamente
morbido leggero flessibile può essere
piegato avvolto senza danneggiarsi ed è
più anche una buona resistenza meccanica
è stato realizzato attraverso un
processo di filatura molto simile a
quello utilizzato per realizzare le
microfibre solo che in questo caso il
processo è coadiuvato dalla presenza di
un campo elettrico
osservato ad un microscopio ad elevato
ingrandimento questo è il modo in cui
questo tessuto fare cioè un intreccio di
fili centinaia di volti più piccoli
rispetto alle microfibre quindi questo
tessuto e tutte le proprietà i vantaggi
dei materiali polimerici e
biocompatibile e piezoelettrico e non
basta è anche estremamente sensibile al
tatto
questo modello molto comune diffuso di
smartphone touchscreen
ogni volta che desideriamo eseguire
un'operazione
premiamo leggermente sulla superficie
del display
in questo modo riusciamo ad abilitare la
funzione desiderata
la pressione che noi applichiamo è pari
a circa 2.000 pascal
proviamo adesso a pensare a quale possa
essere la pressione che una farfalla
esercita su un fiore quando si posa su
di esso
questa è la vanessa del cardo splendido
esemplare di insetto e migratore che
ogni anno micro dalle coste del sud
africa fino al mediterraneo e poi su
fino alla gran bretagna per poi tornare
indietro e concludere il suo ciclo
le farfalle hanno sei zampe e gli
esemplari più piccoli pesano 10 mg
quindi sono in grado di esercitare una
pressione pari a 2 pascal cioè mille
volte inferiore rispetto alla pressione
che noi esercitiamo sul sullo schermo
del del nostro telefonino
ecco il tessuto che vi ho mostrato è in
grado di generare energia a partire da
dalla pressione da una pressione dieci
volte inferiore a quella esercitata
dalla farfalla che si posa su di un
fiore cioè 10 mila volte inferiore
rispetto al nostro tocco gentile quando
utilizziamo lo smartphone
questo
significa che ogni volta che è un
piccolo insetto o anche una foglia o una
debole folate di vento
perturba il tessuto e se potenzialmente
in grado di generare energia elettrica
chiaramente le applicazioni sono
tantissime proviamo a vederne qualcuna
sarà possibile generare l'energia a
partire da qualsiasi forma di movimento
quindi una camminata una passeggiata o
anche le onde del mare onde meccaniche o
anche suoni e rumori e vibrazioni perché
estremamente sensibile anche alle onde
acustiche oppure folate di vento queste
sono questi sono movimenti ai quali
generalmente sono associate delle forze
piuttosto consistenti per cui verrebbe
da pensare va bene anche possibile
magari utilizzare un materiale
piezoelettrico un po più fragile purché
ben impacchettato funzionerà nello
stesso modo
e vero però ci sono tantissime
applicazioni
della vita quotidiana nelle quali secci
pensassimo semplicemente sostituendo il
tessuto microfibra con un tessuto
piezoelettrico potremmo generare energia
elettrica a partire da energia meccanica
spesa che quotidianamente viene spesa ed
inutilizzata
potremmo foderare per esempio tende
tendaggi ombrelloni o anche giacche
antivento per la pioggia perché in
ognuno di questi casi o il vento la
pioggia esercitano una forza sul tessuto
e possiamo raccogliere l'energia che il
tessuto e genera qui sono rappresentate
tantissime altre applicazioni a cui
possiamo pensare pensiamo per esempio al
corpo umano
l'apparato cardiocircolatorio
60 80 battiti minuto significa 60 80
distensione contrazioni in cui
tessuto potrebbe caricarsi per produrre
1 2 volte di tensione che sarebbero
sufficienti ad alimentare un pacemaker
quindi il cuore sarebbe in grado di auto
alimentare il proprio pacemaker oppure
pensiamo al mondo dello sport dove
l'interazione tra il tessuto indossato
il corpo che lo indossa potrebbe
permettere di generare energia o anche
di interagire a livello locale e questo
lo può fare in due modi un modulo
potrebbe essere che il tessuto
memorizza informazione del muscolo sul
quale è posizionato ne seguo il
movimento e queste informazioni possono
essere d'aiuto per tutti coloro che
studiano il logorio muscolare oppure lo
studio della prestazione un altro
possibilità potrebbe essere che ogni
volta che esercitiamo un muscolo
facciamo attività fisica o che comunque
compiamo degli sforzi il tessuto
interagisce col sistema genera alcuni
millivolt anche volte di tensione che
poi può rilasciare al sistema vivente
sotto forma di picchi di energia e in
questo modo è possibile ottenere degli
scopi riabilitativi
ora le applicazioni potrebbero essere
tantissime alcune di queste sono in fase
di sperimentazione presso l'istituto una
nascente e al lecce
il tempo stringe io mi avvio la
conclusione però prima di farlo
vorrei ringraziare lo european research
council che ci ha permesso di iniziare e
proseguire questo meraviglioso viaggio e
soprattutto grazie a voi per
l'attenzione